so the guy from the fountains of wayne
who was writing a play with you based on
your book
yeah the bed wetter yeah the bedwetter
it was a whole thing that was going to
be on broadway
and and and you were all set and this
guy
got covered early on for the past eight
years
we've been writing this musical
um and he and i do the lyrics together
did
and he does all the music and this
amazing writer josh harmon and i wrote
the the words you know the book for it
and um
so what you're saying you're just about
to start we're about to finally start
and i start getting texts we start
getting texts from adam
saying i think i've got this [ __ ]
thing i have like 103
fever and i have a cough
but i can't get a test anywhere you know
and we're just
texting and then a few days after that
he goes
you're not gonna believe where i am i'm
in the [ __ ] hospital with coved
like i have pneumonia from covid and
we're like oh my god you know and
and he's keeping us up to date and we're
texting and then
he stopped texting and i got really
nervous he didn't respond so i called
the hospital
and the hospital said oh he um was
discharged today
so then i text him and i go hey [ __ ]
face answer me when i text you i was
like worried i called the hospital
but he wasn't discharged he was
transferred to a covid only
hospital and then he was immediately put
on a ventilator
and his girlfriend alexis who took care
of him the whole time until she couldn't
be with him anymore in the hospital
kept us up to date every day with what
was going on and they were
trying this experimental thing and then
three days in a row he got
incrementally better but the doctor said
you know
cautiously be cautiously optimistic
and then the next day april 1st he he
died
you must i'm still in shock i mean i
just wait
it's crazy it's crazy how old a guy was
he
he was 52. i never seen him be sick
and then the odd thing is we were with
him he was with his daughters
he was with his girlfriend was nursing
him you know and
none of us got it there's just no
there's no pattern
this guy adam schlesinger what was he
like good guy like um
how did you meet him we had randomly
done stuff together
he had you know like he wrote the crank
anchors theme
and uh it just we were adjacent for a
long time so we did some like
videos together some like music comedy
stuff together
and he's really funny you know and um
so he came over like after i wrote that
book and
he came over and he's like this is a
musical you know so
we just started writing it you know and
um
pushed until like um july but there's no
way
it's gonna happen in july i hope they
stick with it and it's
you know in a year or so